000 tonnes c'est notre chiffre du jour
il s'agit de la quantité d'oignons
récoltés en France en 2021 selon
l'interprofession des fruits et légumes
frais un tiers de cette production est
fourni par la région Centre et ce qui en
fait la première région productrice
d'oignons de l'Hexagone alors que la
récolte des bulbes est terminée les
consommateurs doivent malheureusement
s'attendre à une augmentation de leur
prix Audrey Champigny nous explique
pourquoi à la ferme de La Mothe à Talcy
la famille le maire produit stock et
conditionne ail et chalotes courges et
pommes de terre depuis 4 générations
mais leur légume phare c'est l'oignon
depuis 1997 les cinq frères et deux
cousins ont converti une partie de leur
récolte en bio pour ramasser trier et
emballer ses bulbes l'entreprise emploi
300 personnes
on produit
environ sur 300 hectares des oignons
conventionnels
entre on va dire 60 tonnes les bonnes
années 40 tonnes les mauvaises et en bio
on est un peu plus faible en rendement
puisqu'on a moins de produits chimiques
on va dire on utilise des produits
organiques peut-être dans graisse comme
ça et donc on a des rendements qui sont
nettement inférieurs où on est plutôt
entre 25 30 tonnes hectares mais cette
année la récolte a souffert de la
sécheresse estivale 15 à 20% de
rendement au moins et des charges qui
elles ont explosé plus 10%
d'augmentation salariale plus 30% pour
les emballages recyclables non
plastiques sans oublier le prix de
l'électricité du gaz et de l'essence
tous ces facteurs cumulés ce sont les
producteurs et les consommateurs qui
trinquent
le kilo on a pris un coup de revient de
pas loin de 30 centimes en plus quoi
donc un oignon comment d.050 il faut que
demain puisse vendre 0,80 pour couvrir
augmentation de charge voilà sachant que
on a déjà aussi une augmentation de la
matière première ce qui fait que
aujourd'hui on se doit aussi d'augmenter
encore en plus ce prix vis-à-vis de
l'augmentation de la matière première
qui a doublé par rapport à l'année
dernière quoi
les producteurs de la région Centre
première fournisseuses d'oignons en
France se distinguait pour leur filière
tout en encourageant les consommateurs à
continuer de les soutenir en achetant
leur légume